[Music]
don't have to be happy about Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles it did I know I was
making up these figures it was it kicked
ass over the weekend what do you think's
the secret behind that movie besides you
know yourself yeah thank you for not
making me say that I know yeah you know
I am I am very very excited I I don't
know what the rest first of all look
you've got in my mind it's like you've
got the four Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles who totally kick ass you've got
Megan Fox
yes of course everybody loves and you
can you've got no Jason Bateman and I
feel like not having you know what the
void of I think they're gonna start an
awards category of no Bateman and the
non Bateman goes to as he ever does he
ever tire of your salvos at him
no that's all you to do when he's on he
hung fun of you when you're on do you
make fun of it's the only thing we are
truly like brothers in that way and and
and i truly do dislike him so for me
megan fox incredible she was here the
other night what incredible very nice
but in person i get to see everybody in
person she's so stunning it does my
breath away yeah she is she's very
stunning in fact my my nephew came my
nephews came down from canada to see the
premiere and my twelve year old I
thought like great you know I'm kind of
gonna big-time it for him his uncle's in
this big movie and the fruit I seen the
first thing he says is I'm gonna beat
Megan Fox I was like why are you angry
that happens Thomas yeah calling about
that's the only mom every now and then
she'll say like I'll see you gonna watch
the show tonight my show is on
like me I know say you know it's one of
those weird things about showbiz with
your parents were like yeah we're not
that impressed with you but that guy's
great yeah that there guy yeah that
other guy you did a lot to promote
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles including
you retweeted a picture of Miley Cyrus's
underwear wearing her underwear well we
have the photo here yeah she she tweeted
that out and I figured you know it's if
you retweet a person's crotch maybe
it'll go viral right so just because
look once I know it's terrible yeah you
know and it's OCD I know okay I know
just because she was wearing out
underwear you thought this will help
even more if this gets three other
people in delicious if this guy I feel
like a lot of people were were disgusted
by I didn't take the photo you know
right retweeted honest she does seem
very proud of her vagina yeah yeah in my
defense yes
in your defense lawyer he immediately
became your lawyer miss your honor your
honor she seems very proud of her vagina
case dismissed
let's talk about your Netflix series are
Bojack horseman this is not your average
plot this story no well I mean it isn't
that it's a it's about a guy who's a you
got a human body in a horse head and he
lives in a world and inhabited by by
humans and animals and hybrids therewith
and and then also he's a former 90s
sitcom star who's now in the process of
writing uh his life story so in that
sense it's kind of very spot oh the
pitch was a no brainer kidding it really
is about a former 90s sitcom star who
happens to have a horse's head yeah
anything human body
yeah and he's going through a tough time
in it and it's a really fun it's a very
subversive different and it's me and in
Aaron Paul and Alison Brie and Amy
Sedaris very funny Hopkins yeah yeah a
lot of really really funny people
associated with the show and it's on on
Netflix and and I'm really excited about
I think that it's it is very different
you